hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd unboxing video and this is actually a
slightly larger box than i'm used to but
uh this is actually from the kind folks
at iskin.com
and their their youtube channel
youtube.com iskin.com was kind enough to
ask me if i wanted to do their to be
their first uh youtube featured reviewer
and i said yeah that would be cool so
they they're going to send me out this
special prize and this is the package i
received so i'm gonna do my best to open
this up and give you my give you guys my
first my true first impressions of this
package so uh let's just get right into
this first of all this shipped by ups as
you can see down here and uh it was
pretty good timing so um let's just go
right ahead and see what comes in the
box
and um obviously this is going to be as
much a surprise as this as it is to you
as it is to me um though you probably
already know the product name in the
title or maybe i'll just call it
some eye skin mystery unboxing or
something so
here we go guys this first part might be
a little bit messy
alrighty
i'll probably cut this part out until i
get to the actual box
all right this is the box that i got
after taking the ups packaging off of it
and it says i skin cerulean tx
rx so now i have a a better idea of what
this is so let's just go ahead and uh
take the packaging you know the the
actual box off and you know get a good
look in the first impressions of of this
product and like i said guys earlier uh
the reason that i unbox things so you
guys can see what comes in the package
and you know decide if you really want
to get it or not if it's worth your
money
so
hopefully this is a
good view for you guys this is the ups
shipping information no biggie
and we have what looks like an eye skin
shirt here
wow i'm going to have to get back to you
guys with that
and
inside here
first thing we have is an accessory
pouch looks very nice i'm going to get
to that in a second put this off to the
side
the second thing we have in here is an
eye skin hat
sweet
so the main tech related accessory that
comes in this box as you guys saw before
is the eye skin accessory pouch so i'm
just going to go ahead and uh check out
exactly what the accessory pouch is how
it works see if there's any nice
features about it that you guys might be
interested in if you want to pick one of
these up at the eiskin website so first
thing you'll see is the the pouch itself
and a little manual
here's the actual pouch it's a little
bigger than it looks on the box
and the rest of the box is empty so
that's going to be off to the side
so here is the pouch looks like it has a
hard plastic outside if i can uh you
know get that across you guys on camera
and it's actually a little bit flexible
if you guys can't tell there it is it's
a little bit flexible and it has a
zipper on it so the zipper metallic a
little zipper that says eye skin very
nice
go ahead and unzip this baby
this baby
and we see inside oh nice so it's got a
number of pockets so if we move this off
to the side
the pockets are this uh this little mesh
compartment in this right hand side says
iskin.com there by the way
this little mesh compartment in here we
can fit some of our eye skin accessories
in there
stick that in there and on the left hand
side we have another uh vertical facing
pouch so we can stick things in the left
side and we can just drop things in the
horizontal pouch so that's pretty cool
you can just close it up i'm guessing
this comes in more than one color and if
it does all i'll throw the link so you
guys can check this out in the
description
but that is quite cool of my skin to
send this out to me i'll definitely get
to you guys with a little bit more
information about this pet case and as
you guys saw before they also shipped a
nice little ice skinned hat
and
an eye skinned t-shirt i don't know how
to get this part across you guys but
that is pretty cool an eye skin t-shirt
so you guys thanks for watching this
unboxing video of the little eye skin
mystery package now that we know what's
in the package i'm going to be reviewing
this kinds of stuff um probably within
the month which is what i try to do with
all my review products so thank you for
watching this unboxing video and i'll
catch you guys in the next video and
hopefully you will enjoy this so thanks
for watching guys peace